good morning john so
i'm doing this
apparently let's do a timeline on march
25th elon musk tweeted a poll it said
free speech is essential to a
functioning democracy do you believe
that twitter rigorously adheres to this
principle the next day after 70 of the 2
million people who voted in that poll
said that they did not quote tweeted
that poll saying given that twitter
serves as the de facto public town
square i will give you a de facto public
town square i will not give you the
failing to adhere to free speech
principles fundamentally undermines
democracy what should be done is a new
platform needed not long after that he
announced that he had entered into an
agreement to buy twitter that was a very
loud week and the takes were very hot
but there was a concern that i think has
borne out that elon musk has kind of
viewed twitter from a really particular
lens as a guy who was a billionaire with
80 million followers it's not the most
typical twitter experience one very
well-known effect in the social internet
is that in spaces where harassment is
allowed to sort of run unchecked a lot
of people just leave which is kind of
empowering for the harasser because they
get to see that their harassment has
resulted and the voices of the people
they chased away no longer being heard
in that space and harassment is always
going to affect people with less power
more than people with more power that's
just how it works so i understand people
being concerned by the thought that the
man with the most money in the world
would be in charge of moderation
decisions for a de facto town square
elon's answer to this is that he won't
be in charge of moderation decisions
because all moderation will be based on
whether or not something is illegal and
after i'm sure hearing a lot of
frustration and concern about this he
tweeted this the extreme antibody
reaction from those who fear free speech
says it all by free speech i simply mean
that which matches the law i am against
censorship that goes far beyond the law
if people want less free speech they
will ask government to pass laws to that
effect therefore going beyond the law is
contrary to the will of the people and
then there was a period of time of
around three weeks when people started
to ask elon musk some of the more
complicated questions around speech and
moderation on the internet and then this
week he said this they say something
that is
illegal or otherwise you're just
destructive to the world then then that
there should be perhaps a timeout a
temporary suspension
or that particular tweet uh should be
made invisible or or have very limited
uh traction if there are tweets that are
wrong they should and bad those should
be either deleted or made invisible so
speech that is illegal or otherwise
destructive to the world or wrong or bad
this isn't a man who doesn't want
twitter to do subjective moderation it's
a man who wants twitter's subjective
moderation to work the way he wants it
to and that is because as a lot of
people were saying including me not to
brag no one thought who knew about this
that we were going to end up with a
twitter without subjective moderation
like that's just not on the table where
do you draw the line that's the whole
hard part we were not having an extreme
antibody reaction to the idea of free
speech we were telling him what it would
take him a mere three weeks to figure
out for himself which is that twitter
without subjective moderation cannot
function as of this morning elon musk
says that his deal to buy twitter is
temporarily on hold as he investigates
whether or not twitter's claims about
how many of its users our bots are
accurate i don't know what this means
and and during this sort of initial
hubbub about this i wasn't that
interested in talking about what elon
musk was going to do to twitter because
i knew that this wasn't a done deal and
also by the way he was talking about it
i knew that he hadn't thought really
critically yet about how moderation on a
many-to-many content platform works but
i was really interested in the
conversation that it started about how
difficult moderation is on these
platforms about how yes they have got it
wrong in the past and about how maybe
the problem isn't that twitter like
isn't relentlessly dedicated to the idea
of free speech maybe the problem is that
we have allowed and invited a private
company into the role of de facto town
square that is the thing that seems like
the problem and it doesn't seem like a
problem that gets solved by elon musk
buying twitter but it is a problem that
gets solved by something cause hey
nothing lasts forever jon i'll see you
on tuesday